welcome to podcast ville this podcast is
brought to you by Fuji sports.com listen
if you're doing jujitsu you're jumping
up and down whatever go to Fuji
sports.com right now especially if
you're fat do like me and you need an a5
and a6 I dropped from a 625 it's pretty
interesting they got the nice Saporito
ghee they got the Sakai
they got pads they got they got
everything you understand me you can
roll on [ __ ] what you do is check out
and press in church that's it CH you are
CH I'm gonna give you 15% off why cuz
that's how I wrong alright number two on
it for your supplemental needs like I
told you half a brain is just [ __ ] mack
daddy video yet the way people do
steroids you do the alpha brain do it
for six weeks then you get off for six
weeks you do for six will you do like
brain cycles and during you're not
[ __ ] doing now for brain you're
reading you always go to something
something how'd you take the [ __ ]
mind you got a push to marry it Sudoku
but anyway listen new clues I don't know
a [ __ ] me do puppets whatever what I
want you to do is go to on it calm right
now
let's check out the supplements and on
the way I'm and we'll check out press in
church bad but I'm gonna give me 10% off
cuz that's how I roll alright anyway
it's Wednesday I'm in Nyack New York
maybe tonight I am I'm in New York but
I'm here - don't worry about that I got
a jet the helicopter and three Cubans
were jumping off this [ __ ]
welcome to the Church of what's happened
now take this [ __ ] meal wait are you
[ __ ] nuts the future world champions
in the house sitting here detector
what's happening now future world
champion I appreciate that John Calvin
Gaston man I mean it's no it's a no
[ __ ] brainer gentlemen thank you
thank you for Lisa thank you for coming
up and sitting with us for a while I
mean yeah you're 26 years old you had
your first fight when you were 17 yeah
you come from a wrestling yeah bass
lesson background you're a jujitsu guy
the bootleg planet you know you brown
belt now don't plant a brown belt
congratulations nothing and you don't
mind
throwing some [ __ ] punches no you
don't mind staying in the pocket every
once in a while and showing you true
[ __ ] blood am saying which is you
want to do this will do this [ __ ]
well it turned out I'm pretty good at it
so I stuck with it thank you thank you
for being here tonight know you're 26
your next fight is made 12 against
Jacare Jacare so that's a huge test and
at 26 you have to look at it objectively
you could going in [ __ ] bang with
them and knock them down mm-hm
or whatever and you don't wanna lose in
this situation at 26 you're going
through you're world champion and from
every step you're gonna learn something
and get stronger and stronger and
stronger absolutely actually you're
naturally talented you're lightening
[ __ ] quick insanely you get from
point A to point B and you got dynamite
in your heads it was a thank you
what the [ __ ] does it take to be a
fighter bro that's crazy man that you
asked me I was actually gonna say cuz um
a lot of people kinda asked me the same
thing you got a lot of guys on Instagram
I'm a guy Calvin I'm sixteen seventeen
years old man I look up to you what did
you do to get to where you're at
uh-huh but I mean the answer is always
the same I mean there and there is no
secret answer the answer is is is is
through hard work and winning fights you
know I mean you gotta really be prepared
to win fights and win big fights you
know I mean there is no secret everybody
wants to know what the secret is what
the secret diet what you do with the
secret pill to lose weight no it's just
through hard work a good diet if you if
you if that's your goal but it's through
hard hard work well determination and
being at the right place at the right
time I mean that's it I mean you got
until the fighter which [ __ ] people
dream about yeah it's from all over the
world of 1500 that's been firing on I'm
[ __ ] training to audition for Dana
why can you imagine that
like that you dream well I'm not
knocking I'm just saying that's a
tremendous dream to have yeah then they
get chosen to be on the opening Friday
then win the [ __ ] Ultimate Fighter
now I have that's a complete different
situation you how old when you won the
Open final 21
amazing Bailey yeah Bailey
I remember looking back at the room when
I went to the tryouts in Vegas because
they put on a sign say tryouts will turn
fire from middleweights and light
heavyweights so come on out and and so I
went out and there's about 500 guys 500
beasts you know we just blacked out in
this background that you know I've done
this he's won the World title in this
and I just remember looking back and all
these guys and just be mesmerized for
the first time in my life like oh my god
what am I doing here
for with all these guys you know I'm
just a guy from Yuma Arizona or a small
little town you know and there's a bunch
of tough guys in the room I felt low
intimidated you know and what did they
make you do at the tryouts well they
they split you up into groups so split
split group Group one two and three you
know for example they they call up group
one group one goes into a big room and
there's a big room with you know at the
time Joe Silva and the matchmakers and
in the producers of the show as well
they put a group a in the room there's a
big mat in the middle of the room and
Joe Silva would be calling from his from
from where he was at there was a big
table you know and so he'd be calling
so-and-so go to the mat and and
everybody had two minutes to wrestle and
showcase their skills yeah I mean a lot
of press wrestled low punches
no just jujitsu start on your knees joe
says go two minutes on the clock and
then you you go with him another guy you
know in the wrestle for two minutes Joe
says okay he looks at the file next boom
he comes up the next two guys didn't say
nothing you know this ain't nothing he's
just all right boom so it's all two
minutes and then BOOM and why
everybody's watching you know
and then that goes on for about 50 50
minutes to an hour and then you go to
the striking to the striking Department
you hit mitts with coaches that are
there and then there's Joe Silva walking
around with a clipboard like okay you
can go sit down
then just checking you off the reel then
okay you can go sit down
you know and it's intimidating
it's intimidation this little guy this
little guy with the clipboard or you
know and you're super intimidated while
he's walking around with his clipboard
checking people off because this is your
dream you know you want to be able to do
good you want to impress him you know
this is this is the dream that you've
been working on for for a long time then
what's the third test Tuesday and then
the third test and then the third test
after that was done Joe said Joe Silva
says okay guys well a lot of you guys at
the end at the end of that at the end of
that session he calls guys okay guys the
next couple guys I'm gonna call made it
through the guys that don't call I'm
sorry next time just like that you know
and so they call up about half half the
group they call up to go on to the next
round the next round Joe Joe Silva says
it's the hardest part
guys like Benson Henderson went through
it and failed guys like Frankie Edgar
went through it and failed it's the TV
part I guess which was the hardest part
where you got to show like personality
and housing and I mean I'm just I'm just
a shy little guy from 21 year old 20 at
the time 20 at the time 20 year old from
from a little town in you mind how do
you showcase your personality yeah I
don't know so I went in there and I was
just me I just went in there and and and
they told me well Calvin you're you're
five no twenty years old um we like you
and then my my heart started beating you
know I relaxed a little bit but I was
like well I like you guys do and
and that was it it must have been 60
seconds while everybody else was taking
five minutes to go in and out of that
room with the producers and that was the
crazy part too because the producers you
go into a little a smaller room and they
put a camera in front of you and they
get about 10 producers behind that
camera and they're all staring at you on
the other end and they're all asking you
questions and that was crazy
you know just a lot of a lot of pressure
in that trial as if it's pretty crazy
it's that's part of the business it's
that you have to look good on TV and I
look good but my appeal they're creating
a storyline it's reality TV I know I
always do it have to stuff with that but
I didn't know if you sparred the first
[ __ ] day it's just
unlicensed they go they go at it in
those two minutes I mean they are going
at it like guerrillas in those two
minutes that they're trying out and
doing jujitsu for Joe Silva who was at
the time the matchmaker you know he was
the man yeah now ah was the house
journey for seven weeks seven weeks no
cell phones no cell phones no TV no
radio no outside communication yeah
seven days a week you're going to the
gym and to the house twice a day seven
days a week yeah it's intense with the
same [ __ ] be and then you're living
with some Ellen farts or Heaphy playing
pranks yeah all of that you know I was
with a good group of guys to be honest a
lot of the guys all of them fought in
the UFC which Danan has never think has
ever
besides the Ultimate Fighter where he
gives everybody a contract so now you
[ __ ] 21 you win the earth I mean when
you were 12 were you dreaming of
fighting no no never never I was
wrestling I was wrestling just trying to
become a wrestler and also meet you on
this big stage yeah man I remember I
remember
walking out to that Ultimate Fighter
finale and just feeling overwhelmed and
I wanted to cry because I just remember
being in the tunnel before I walking out
before walking out to that fight just be
like wow all this time imagining being
here and I'm here and I was just just
came over this is this feeling of
overwhelming yes do you still get
overwhelmed I don't think so no I'm
gonna get a warm sometimes when you walk
into it
octagon again somebody you know Jesus
cooking I mean you want to begin three
doorbell for correct yeah this is
somebody that you watched yeah years ago
on today you watch them you watch them
destroy people you watch them lose you
watched big feet or oh yeah right
and here you are across you got the gray
doorbell yeah you know I told you you
were at the Comedy Store Tuesday night
great light great wine amazing then we
went to the back and Joe shilling was
there I was amazed what everybody was
talking Thursday night you know I'm
sitting back there I've been doing this
twenty seven years and I still get
overwhelmed at times in those situations
which on the drive home it's just coming
down from that naturally I don't bring
brief from my car mm-hmm I don't like it
they gave us a choice to smoke smoke in
your [ __ ] house in your yard but to
be puffing you call you asking for
trouble that's right but you felt that
way when Thursday had to bring up more
along hmm hmm okay no no big deal for
some people no big deal
I still remember renting the tapes the
best of def Comedy Jam when I was
starting out with a pencil on a piece of
paper and watching him you know and
going jesus [ __ ] christ he's
delivered this guy you know amazing
and listen 27 years driving up Laurel
Canyon I quote Lee I just brought up
Martin [ __ ] Lena that's amazing I
love Jeff Ross Sebastian oh and I'm like
Here I am 55 years old which most people
in this career would be [ __ ]
I'm overwhelmed that's amazing it's it's
so I can and I thought though I can't
imagine walking into the Octagon as
tough as you are with the but the the
[ __ ] weapons you have and looking up
and seeing a dude you sat around with
your buddies you drinking beer watch
yeah six seven years ago eight years ago
you know yeah you there's a sense of
ovale overwhelming las' is that what the
words the words like that overwhelmed
but not in the sense that that oh my god
I didn't know what the heck is going on
and in the sense that that the this is a
big deal and I'm nervous about it like
before walking out you get torn I call
it a tornado of emotions I mean you're
happy you're scared you want to cry you
want to laugh you want to you want to do
well it's a tornado of emotions you know
and that's that's the overwhelming part
that's the part that you've gotta learn
how to handle or else it can mess you up
I mean all these nerves all of this this
tension inside of you
you gotta learn how to how to channel it
and how to how to UM yeah I don't tell
it really has a comic as a comedian when
I watch a fight with me when I watch a
fight the walk is that most intriguing
thing from me mmm-hmm I don't even think
of a fight no more like nice to do the
shows with Joe it's very important for
sure it was very important to me to go
to the way it is very important I always
watch the way i watch the guys reaction
at the weigh-in because let me tell you
something my friend Kevin Gaston me it's
the same for me when that blue light
comes out and that comic is on stage I'm
next
I'll have you two sitting back there
howling laughing at the comic before me
mm-hmm
and that blue light comes on which means
I got about three minutes and I'd take
that swig of water I got up I pull my
shirt down
I pull my jacket on
you have no idea or like the emotions
that you're feeling it's kinda like the
tornado of emotion it's a tornado
emotions but I've only got a ten-foot
walk so I have 10 feet to fake the funk
as I call it the funk I'm falling apart
inside I'm falling apart first I am
dying inside I am getting kicked by 20
Porto Ricans in the Bronx in 1968 that's
what you feel like for sure and then you
hit the stage and your knee buckles this
time is my knee buckles my knee buckles
it's a 6-inch thing and then you get up
you shake the guy's hand you give them a
hug and once you touch that microphone
we were talking about the story and
right right I remember what we were
talking about the psychology of it that
walk to me
when I watch a fighter walk in and he's
jumping up oh my god if it was me I
would run like - and then dirty feet
before I saw [ __ ] what's the cops
name or the black dude Herb Dean yeah I
just turn around and roll and put it run
into the audience like I couldn't
imagine that walk some guys walk real
slow I would have to run and then
running the cage and like put a cop on
me to make sure I wouldn't know yeah
that's how scared I would be like ya
know you're behind this curtain they got
a big big freaking light in your face
they tell you okay you got 30 seconds
there's the countdown and then this
whole time you're getting all this
adrenaline rush going through your body
you're like ah you know like I'm really
go now forget the 30 seconds and they're
trying to pull my shirt like you can't
go now and I'm like [ __ ] let me go
you know I want to go and fight doubt
like you just get a disability and rush
you're scared you're happy at the same
time you know at what point do you lose
it when your foot hits the mat but but I
get what you're saying with the with the
before walking out to the stage you do
feel like oh yeah I fake the funk you
have to I fake
you know right now that walk to the
stage for me you have to I'm ready to
get in the [ __ ] car and run home I'm
saying I'd never come out of my house
again
absolutely that walk is a fake walk if
there's ever been a faith walk ever you
know you have to fix it's fake you tell
you make it fake it til you get there
and worry about and once I touch the
microphone I don't know that's like your
jab that's your first it's not the first
once you throw it's you the first punch
I throw the first punch I get thrown
that the same is I'm crapping my pants
on the way to the to the arena you know
and as soon as my my I threw that first
punch all those nerves are gone I'm
concentrating 100% on what's in front of
me that's when I truly feel when I'm
living in the moment because I'm cause
concentrating 110% in what's in front of
me now when you've been the fight you've
lost fights yeah has ever been a fight
that you've been in that you thought you
were gonna lose and you ended up [ __ ]
doing something crazy well what was your
toughest opponent you think are you
always go in there thinking I'm gonna
win but deep down inside there's always
this other there's a doubt there's no
doubt for sure
you know and I think in my opinion I
feel like every fighter goes in there
with their mindset like yes I'm there to
win but there's a real possibility that
I can get knocked down or some guys just
don't think they can get knocked down
they go in there bad things happen you
know but it's it's it's a mentality
thing it's crazy I daddy how about
getting knocked out in front of a
million people waking up you know last
week thank god I've never been knocked
down dawg
that's a minute but you know it's funny
how a couple weeks ago Hector Lombard
threw that late punch and he knocked
that dude out not doing up saying what
happened CB Dollaway what happened
that's a heart I like them for me in
front of a million people
to get up and then walk it out and not
really know what happened and see all
those people like that could happen on
the street by yourself yeah but for it
to happen like all those parts of that
aspect of fighting I have always
intrigued me because I compared them to
bombing and then walking out in front of
the people all bombing yeah and standing
outside after the show and people
walking past you without saying nothing
to you for sure really feeling bad
yeah it's the same type of emotions
annoyed but like I said every fighter I
feel like in my opinion at least I do I
go in there with her in my mind with
certain reality set in my mind that I
can get knocked out I could get
submitted just don't that happen just
don't let it happen so this fight is
made twelfth when do you start your
official training camp well we're about
nine weeks away so I I already started
training for this fight but now I'm
doing so this is 185 yeah no no wait
Nidalee
that [ __ ] mule a break the [ __ ]
thing gets me back use me rough no so
now this is so you're already in
training camp now you're in the yeah and
we soy okay how use what is a usual
training yet no man it's about eight to
ten weeks of just training you know
getting you know getting in shape making
sure it stays a week six days a week
describe the week Monday Monday Monday
so Monday Wednesdays and Fridays I'm at
Kings MMA okay
well actually pretty much every day on
my king's Ameri but Monday Wednesday
Fridays is when we do I do it together
with the whole pro team
okay the whole pro team gets together
and then in the evenings I go with the
amateur team somewhat of an amateur team
on Mondays and then Tuesdays I'm going
on Tuesdays and Thursdays I'm going
straight to conditioning twice a week in
there in the evenings on Tuesdays and
Thursdays I'm either working my jujitsu
or working my
my mints working mints reppin and then
Saturdays I'm doing splints it's the
only and last workout of the week and
Sprint's at the heart that's good [ __ ]
though its top stronger than [ __ ]
sprints when you combine it with ever oh
yeah now I've been doing that I will you
can buy ice let me get older broke and
Boulder Colorado is a health capital of
the country Michael back in the 80s
and I got to learn a lot like read your
name everybody does something mm-hmm
when you look at the entertainment guide
and Bouldin when I lived there
it was hiking to see the moon you know
hiking looking for wool outdoor activity
outdoor activities so I got the that's
me interesting people and other guys
that live down for me crazy what I mean
they know things that well a lot of
people don't
it's really [ __ ] crazy the guy down
the corner from me was at that time a
kinesiology major but you're ready was
strength and conditioning coach with
color Colorado a while in Colorado had a
big black dude that was a strength and
conditioning coach that was well known
and he was his understudy in him he had
his thing was running 40 yards hundred
yards he believed his sprinter he
believed in sprinting for training yeah
any type of training for strength for
sure he was like that's the [ __ ] that
nobody wants to do any what's the base
of [ __ ] it's it's the hardest thing
because it just is to hold your just
exploding your whole body you know no
other workout is like a sprint it's what
my trainer sends it just it's just the
the the type of reaction your body gets
no other workout gets it like that you
don't train any other aspect your body
doesn't react the same than in any other
workout only in Sprint's strength and
conditioning has become a big part of it
now Oh years ago nobody gave a [ __ ] now
they know that huge human have to keep
your muscles lubricated you have to
stretch for surely you came at all
cuffed up I mean I was a weekday you
copy
um don't once we
that's great once a week up and then
once a week massage as well and that's a
lot it helps a lot for recovery you know
I mean I was somebody was telling me
that they were having lunch with Dan
Gable thank it was one of the greatest
wrestlers that have lived American
wrestler and one of the most
accomplished as well and he trained like
a madman you know and he's got all these
secrets and it's got all these ways of
doing things that the wrestlers look up
to him a lot you know but one thing he
says you wish you would have focused on
was recovery I wish I would have a focus
more on recovery back in my day and then
I would have been able to do more people
have no idea how important well I tried
bro I when I can't think you got hit in
the head with uh what a [ __ ] lunch
box and my mother put me in karate dog
and can't stay I was you know I was in
New York City I hit in the head in
Central Park you know and I have a five
year old now and I was telling Eddie and
his children son's birthday party I go
you're a trap tremendous black belt you
wanted to talk buy boats in the country
and your son is six and you can't
explain jiu-jitsu to him why it's
important cause I know it's been tough I
know my daughter doesn't comprehend her
karate yet she doesn't comprehend that
she's five if the guy comes in on
Wednesdays and teaches a mime location
that you could go if you want
mm-hmm I go to all the graduations and
stuff but she doesn't know it's for
self-defense
you don't comprehend it for self-defense
do you get hit in the [ __ ] head right
and I didn't know my [ __ ] point was
but a couple years ago I got really
heavy from the sleep apnea and the drugs
and just focusing on comedy you know
comedy was such a big part of my life at
the time that I was living the lifestyle
that one of the more you know if ten
years ago if I would have bumped into
you and 1:00 in the morning me you
Victor robed in those days yeah
stop well don't eat are we standing here
where's house let's go to [ __ ] know
which one we had to go to
enters okay any pastrami sandwich is a
french fries and then onion soup and
[ __ ] crackers and we'd sit there for
two hours til [ __ ] 3:00 in the morning
and whenever you don't need give it up
cuz you know we the three of us have
been smokin you know it's [ __ ] crazy
so I blew up the 418 pounds
Wow down at 270 hmm and then I went up
to like 340 once I had the kid I joined
you JIT so I said that's it d cuz I'm
too old to [ __ ] be doing tango box
that [ __ ] like that and it was so weird
that even in my journey there from there
that now the five years I've been
messing around with it right now I'm
working smarter and you have to I was
going in there and I wanted to do what
Kelvin was doing and if Kelvin said
let's go one more round because it's my
brother cow I'd do it again
sure and again and again again the next
thing I'm opened up now so at 50 yeah I
could open up I can open up and
breathing and I can get there and I
could drink BCAAs and I know that it's
two hours later when I go to get out of
the car now you're 50 this little test
there's lower testosterone me yeah I
whack off i do i do kettlebells
testosterone was my damn shame I knocked
my wife of the 50 dogs yeah [ __ ] with me
but I gotta tell you something though
the fire so now when I roll I rolled
twice a week I go to jujitsu only twice
a week and I do three five-minute rows
35,000,000 roll three fives and I do the
technique I drill the technique you want
to drill afterward I'll drill arm Basra
to you and guard passes and the whole
thing with you but after three rolls it
defeats the purpose for me yeah it
defeats the purpose because I also got a
Muay Thai conditioning at night oh nice
so from nine to ten so I want to go to
four training sessions you know what
primal animal I smoked that dope in the
morning it gets my vibrating my god I
feel like Kelvin I'm gonna go to coffee
one cup one cup one cup yogurt with
wheat German old school to fight the
[ __ ] HIV
what's the other [ __ ] they're nuts great
nuts okay I'll do that and I'll shoot
over there just on that you know no eggs
nothing but it's funny that all I could
do is four times a week you have to be
very realistic with your expectations
yeah and recovery is very important
super important oh yeah I'm not having a
home
super important I wasn't drinking I was
in Dortmund but when I get home about
what that means I don't fall asleep till
2:00 yeah that means I'm up at 7:00 with
the five year old that means the whole
damn walking around halfway wounded
don't get me wrong I've learned that
there's some days there some days they
go by that way but recovery is so
important and I didn't know it till I
got diagnosed with sleep apnea when I
had to sleep apnea Jesus Christ that was
the biggest weight gain or a super super
important summer important is sleeping
getting your rest oh yeah sleep is
another is [ __ ] huge yeah dad I want
to kick boxing conditioning on Sunday
yeah and then I have to go to two kids
parties brought home at 4:30 by five
o'clock Papa tapped out I got a pretend
I hate and I had a spot at nine oh now
that's completely different
wow I can get a pretend to eight and
make conditioning shower have a cup of
coffee tweet you know certainly they can
have a good day have a good day yeah and
then [ __ ] but the mind that was weird
I haven't got up drink coffee something
take a hot shower and then talk to
myself on the way down to the drive and
then when I got there people were
talking to me they had it in jet you
know how to talk to them so I could
loosen up and I had an old case and I
had a bag of dicks but had a little case
that the same baddies thing it's kind of
will how now I really gotta take care of
myself have - you have - I just had a UH
who's like my grandmother she had her
stomach cut in about half earn about a
little ball I don't know what that
surgery is called yeah the gastric
bypass
gastric bypass surgery then exactly she
just had it done I mean you know weights
over
getting problem for her and she
struggled with it all her life she's 50
it's 15 now and she had the surgery done
and she lost like 40 pounds last month
it was it was crazy it was crazy it's
really because you know you know eating
eating habits our problem for a lot of
people when I take those edibles [ __ ]
Hercules can't stop me dog I'll pick
that [ __ ] up the [ __ ] neck
right every dance of my way between me
and the cabinets but I'm pretty good
like I attack fruit first yeah apples
only so I go to Weight Watchers
oh wait watches my seat because a high
protein it's still high protein she was
on it as well my own [ __ ] yeah that's
shit's good [ __ ] man so I go there and
so I could eat all the chicken I want I
can eat all the seafood like not salmon
you know that's all free fruit is free
beans are free like yeah yeah that is
eggs are free I love eggs so yes there
that is I had rice and beans
I put eggs on everything oh my god I
wish I could eat eggs like that like I
really if I scrambled them with some
green chili yeah like some [ __ ] New
Mexico or in style chili no cheese no
potatoes I grew up on eggs off all there
was in my fridge worn up was eggs and
milk um tortillas oh my god and beans
and that works bro and that's where I
grew up on listen eggs and beans and a
tortilla that [ __ ] works with some salsa
what if there's no cheese's also work
huh
it's all there was the evening today but
this is I know I so I love it I love it
I put it on everything when I saw you
the other night I'm like this kid fights
the way he does because he's a young man
he's still like a [ __ ] sponge
yeah that's wrong when you were walking
up the stairs I go how do you know yeah
oh my god it just [ __ ] my whole mind
up my right mind set up a by you
I mean I mean I've been in public eye
now
five years and it's been it feels like
it's been 10 years you know a lot has
happened in the five years and I've
grown you know I guess I've matured a
lot and in the public eye and they've
seen me you know they see me grow young
man to almost 27 year old now later this
year it's just been an incredible
incredible incredible journey you know
we were giggling on the way and I said
show up at this time because I do a
periscope I don't want you to test
positive for the reef yeah when you came
in before the show study you kind of
told me that told us the story of how
its twelve hours before the fight or
something right so when I got caught was
was I read up on all the rules of course
I had to read up on it and figure it out
for myself and I found out that that
that they test for that only in
competition and what was on in
competition was they consider it 12
hours before the bout so if you saw that
comes to my gym a week out and I test
positive fatigue see what happens
nothing I still fight I still get my
purse but at the same time you gotta be
under the TV satellite we limit which I
believe is 150 which is a [ __ ] are you
sitting in that chair no you sitting in
that chair
oh yeah probably I don't know you test
positive for THC now and we all have to
go to court me and Lea with the dance
with my metabolites except take samples
off the wall it's probably never seen
we've been in this office for [ __ ]
charge like sadly they really haven't
know we've been in this office for two
years not know how much th it's gotta be
every time I vacuum I get to sell it to
the weeds oh yeah this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
good eyes on dispensary down it's
[ __ ] crazy twelve so yeah big flowers
yeah that was a big blow man that sucked
when that happened lesson learned I got
pulled off the Anderson Silva fight in
Rio
you know I lost my bonus that I had for
that fight in there and you know I like
I said I got pulled off the fight which
was potentially more more money for the
fight you know and then was suspended
for three months for first violation
you're never do it again
yeah exactly saying like that was a big
blow especially in the pockets I mean I
must have lost yeah 100 grand no no
that's what I heard yeah that's when you
go okay I get the next time now we
understand your complaint though nothing
that I was a little [ __ ] confused now
yeah you know the limit we know her
limits and stuff so now you're gonna
stay at 185 well to be honest now nobody
knows this but I was I was considering
going going down to 175 I was they were
even considering giving me a fight at
170
in Chile they wanted me to handle line
it and nobody knows that but I I
contemplated it over a few weeks like
two weeks with my manager you know just
going back and forth like give me walk
around there like 205 but I contemplated
because I was just going back and forth
with my managers saying like yeah just
give me the best 170 guy in the world
you know I want the guy that'll get me
the title shot or give me the best 185
guys that would get me the title shot
and it just it just it just turns out
that they wanted me to fight somebody
that I I didn't not in the top five
which I wanted to I wanted to fight
someone in the top five somebody that'll
get me the title shot but um they didn't
want to give me somebody like that they
wanted to give me a top 15 guy so I was
like well that's a risk you know I'm
fighting the realistically possibly I'm
about two or three fights away from a
title shot at 170 185 I'm I win one or
two more I was a Caray - and he's ranked
second yeah so you go you jump over
Jacare your
you could talk about it well you're the
last fight you beat those chant like he
was a champ for weeks before your fight
someone that's right that's right so he
was the number two ranked when he he
fought me now I get to fight Jacare
who's ranked number two and hopefully
gets me in line for the title shot next
time hopefully you have me all next time
I bring the belt bring it right here
yeah no I hope I wish you all the luck
in the world Europe you're a great young
man I mean 20 [ __ ] sushi just a
handle not just fighting but what goes
with it man listen I love comedy bro I
love doing I love it I love it I just
got into it and I've been following you
guys for a while now but no I love doing
comedy the way you love fighting sure
there comes a point though sometimes you
go why must there be all this drama just
for me to do what I want to do right I
got a white shirts I got a do this have
people knocking at my door six the more
they want a sample of blood who does
this not even Dracula does that they
want blood at 6:00 in the morning I
gotta wait I got two hours but it's
insanity nice you go that's what people
don't really understand it's that
lasting through what goes around your
manager shorts you on the check awesome
they find them in a brothel with three
hook this writing the kadosh Ian's ex
buddy foaming from the mouth and now you
gotta get a new manager it's it's all
this [ __ ] that trying to focus on what's
in front of you yeah all this [ __ ] going
around you it's Bernard
oh yeah it's hard it's hard it's hard at
my age I can't imagine doing what you're
doing 2006 I was doing that toy since I
was doing time oh yeah that's great at
26 hours and thinking about nothing I
was thinking about just surviving
everyday basis I didn't give a [ __ ]
about anything else that's crazy I
really so you got Jacare now jesus
[ __ ] christ may 12th which is three
months away but in reality it's three
weeks away like you know that's how fast
I'm going oh yeah when the clock is
ticking oh yes
when you're in camp once that four-week
market now it settles in now that's when
you're oh my god four weeks away that's
three weeks of training plus fight week
you know that's that's coming up short
and time goes go ahead fight week is
drama week in other words go downstairs
talk to the media your side kicks in
public I want to throw this [ __ ] I got I
do this in the mirror for myself I'm
saying oh yeah they went outside the
hotel oh my god I can't imagine well I
see public workouts like whatever they
call my open workout yeah yeah I [ __ ] my
[ __ ] pants like I would snap after
three minutes I got the preeminence get
the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out enough enough
coming down here look at the guys go get
on a bicycle your flip-flops or cameras
it's a little scary sometimes I mean I
got all these these eyes look at you and
you get a little overwhelmed
hey me you know I'm not a guy that's
always been used to the spotlight I like
to kind of lay low and kind of stay out
of eyesight you know and so a guy like
me when spotlights on I get overwhelmed
I like it panic attacks almost you know
but you got to learn how to deal with it
you have to you have to you know we were
talking about entertainment I was still
I don't know who the [ __ ] I was talking
to him about I go IRA learned a lot
about entertainment from wrestlers but I
did the longest she all right yeah how
those guys behaved towards the public
hmm compared to the movie stars in the
movie how they would hide wrestlers were
out there yeah talking to people shaking
hands you know hugging people yeah Steve
Austin oh wow
Kevin Nash oh wow and we have one more
guy that was doing stunts a song he was
arrested for getting blasted those guys
were living like goddesses oh yeah they
even got to like to give you watch The
Longest Yard the guards
went to Adam Sandler's Elizabeth yeah
it will ananda set by 10 what's gonna
start drinking and they brought a
blender in and they would send a [ __ ]
ad to get beers everything oh it's like
oh and go burke yeah I remember we would
do is we would lock Goldberg's door from
the inside no and he was everyday with
the door yeah just wrap it there like
nothing like nothing off the [ __ ]
hinges he would rip it just that is HUGE
he was huge I remember him it was
something that don't called as well
called was at that time this is 2004 he
was still stone-cold oh I just did this
podcast he said he was dog
I was drinking with three [ __ ] hands
said that they were [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] up bad that's a complete
different world
oh yeah no I mean that dude was the face
of WWE year Wi-Fi at the at one point
steep tone Cold Steve Austin Goldberg I
mean those are all big time guys they
get paid a lot of money a lot of money
let me get some shoutouts I'm gonna get
this [ __ ] party started here sadqa'
tact whatever it's your birthday again
[ __ ]
knock it off over there in Japan
Christopher Owens paulrobinson Marcelo
Manos Joey O'Neill Abel Zoran Jena
Jackson sergio ortega the Man of Steel
Blanc RadioShack and my favorite juice
place the greenhouse juice over on
lactation going in tell them uncle Joey
says that she's real over there dog but
is it they got like these [ __ ] my
friends from a conditioning class goes
Brown went over they started drinking me
they got everything they got [ __ ] come
pooch on tap ok they got [ __ ] ki khel
there for the first time I wouldn't try
cattle if you paid me we can but they
don't put the stems in it ok so you
don't taste nuttin it tasted delicious
ok and you know me though I don't like
talking tasty chef yeah
tastes good I love my Dolce but he's got
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] on his diet
you're I'm saying like that would say
would always [ __ ] like that I need that
[ __ ] which one
you know I'm King waterfall yeah I never
got a lot of he knows he's got a lot of
canola and I don't like that [ __ ] he's
got a lot of lot of stuff but he's got
to some good recipes in the book he's
got three or four he's legit good
[ __ ] recipes he's got a couple
breakfast recipes though they yummy you
just gotta tell me I don't like honey
I've been able to work with Mike long
time ago I work with Mike and he was so
good so good well you don't like honey
oh right like honey honey honey honey so
what do you like about it the texture
makes me [ __ ] gang I barely like me
remember I just don't like on here right
though [ __ ] honey I like honey over
somebody man like acai bowls which I
never really had those are good but they
make a thing called the antioxidant it's
like acai juice pomegranate juice
it's [ __ ] it's pretty good you had a
little protein scoop you're tip-top
Magoo you ready things out you say
you're trying to work it out know what I
wanted to say to you was I'll never
forget this like this had to be the
first Expo I was really excited about
and I go Joe let's go in Thursday and he
said I'm not going down there I gotta do
a talk with Goldberg on stage that's
gonna be [ __ ] crazy so I asked
somebody you're sitting over your past
not went down there and I'm not gonna
say his name just fired her dog he was
surrounded
and he'll have a look on his face like
he wanted a shooting son what does he
suffer from social anxiety brows too
much this is why at that time I walked
around the expo the first time I go you
know do you remember when Rocky was
training in the gym yeah and then it for
two or three he started going to a
casino yeah
to Train mm-hmm yeah but the old man
quit something happened didn't wanna
train a variety that's what it feels
like
Oh like well they take you to those
things you know what they should really
ask the fighters are you into this and
you went to throwing sidekicks in public
and talking to 200 people afterward or
or they should give them classes or how
done how to deal with it well it seems
like from what I've seen recently that
if you want to be a star unfortunately
it's kind of like having social media we
probably if we had a choice from when we
might not have it or be on it as much
but to be a star in the UFC you kind of
have to be in front of the TV cameras
yeah one thing is huge about the UFC the
fans get to interact with them uh you
know no other sport I think has more
interaction with with the athletes than
you have seen you know what I mean you
got an ID you think of a will you know
think of a world where I could tweet
Julius Erving tonight mm-hmm I could
tweet you I could tweet neighbor I could
tweet Anderson Silva he won't get back
to me but if I keep tweeting and
eventually sure he'll get back to me one
day he'll know this and I'm the real
deal I'm his fan you have this contact
man with people that you know that
contact was before right in your life
even if you say things on their page or
whatever
absolutely so it's a different world
when I was growing others no contact
yeah yeah and you had a [ __ ] poster
of Kevin gasps tlemen on my wall that's
it yeah
Kevin gas them and then go to McDonald's
and shake hands on Saturday the first
the eurozone like that didn't [ __ ] can
happen like unless I bumped into you
at the hotel or something like that you
know it's funny the first time first
couple times I saw you fight I was in
the middle of reading the Roberto Duran
story ok book by Drew I think you
remember telling they turned it into a
[ __ ] movie in the movie suck dick
because 20 is too late nobody knows
Ranbir Duran is but during his time you
and you obviously you've seen him yeah
you've seen him flying things on people
huh you told the one fight where he just
follows vicious you always reminded me
something in your face the way you bang
on and it's funny that that persona for
a lack seat do you have seats really
tried for years to open up the Latino
door and they've 16 Mexico they really
have they've done a great [ __ ] job
and my phone yeah they've done a great
job in a lot of good places but they
never had like a Mexican guy that talked
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know they're not like
just talk [ __ ] and throw the microphone
and speaking Spanish and bad words and
[ __ ] no [ __ ] bananas yes yes yeah
why is his recent interview he was
talking smack to triple G's man trainer
you know how it just kind of opens his
mouth all the time he just tested hot
dope Canelo right oh yeah mutual no need
to get the fights going on still they
said that as soon as the tested positive
they were still gonna fight yeah no no
nothing has been sanctionable
clenbuterol or something like that is
the steroid I I don't know what type of
steroid or painting it is but it I guess
it's a PD it's considered a PD
I'm not sure what it does but I guess
it's it's found in a lot of the meat in
Mexico and so if he's eating tacos I'm
in the mineral camp and he'll probably
test if some of that meat is
contaminated with with that because they
give it to the animals in Mexico to make
them grow foul
so I think open bigger bigger or faster
one of them - they give him steroids and
so a lot of Mexican fighters and even if
you look back I guess a couple of years
ago at the Australian is that we I think
the last mmm World Cup the Mexican the
Mexican team had tested for Colombia all
because of them contaminated me at the
steroid
yeah it's PD I'm not sure what it is
this is it Vince
it thins the blood for more oxygen oh
wow yeah that's the so if you get more
oxygen you get more just go more and for
weight loss maybe I think it says though
too
so they're still young boxing they don't
give a [ __ ] jack you just show up with
your beautiful beautiful
Diana ball the cousin don't look II and
the go what he want to do here oh good
yeah I thought I was interesting cuz I
got the same I got an email from your
sada when I was fighting in China like
be careful of the meet in China make
sure you go to all these high-end
restaurants instead of going down on the
butcher and just getting your meat there
something really because it's
contaminated clenbuterol and athletes
have tested positive for for clenbuterol
but no nothing has been sanctioned
against them because they know the
circumstance but they gotta they gotta
do something about it I feel like I
don't know the people stuff in the meat
yeah maybe order because they they know
it's it's a problem like like the Mexico
national team had tested positive for it
like I said this Mexican national soccer
team so now every supplement you take
you said it to you sat at first you have
to send them a list well I I don't ever
take something nothing nothing nothing
wrote a scared the crap out of me too so
that's it you just where you're like no
I'm not taking nothing
I'm not even risking it you know you go
to these athlete retreats where they you
solder representatives come in and they
talk to you and they just scare the crap
out of you you know they give
list of all these 800 supplements and
you're just looking at it it's gibberish
to me I don't know what any of these
things are but if I test positive for it
then I'm swap you know so you don't go
to GNC you know nothing you don't do
[ __ ] no no protein powder I can massage
once a week okay no I do I do protein
now now that I that I replace it with a
meal or something every now and then you
know I got a whey protein yeah yeah well
yeah that goes up my mm-hmm yeah you
gotta be [ __ ] care yeah they they
scare the crap out of you it's crazy and
the [ __ ] P like I didn't know was
that bad HBO of one of those do the
thing about vitamins mm-hm about two
years ago three years to make vitamins
cuz there's no regulation on it they
showed this it's not somebody's not a
body showed G ensign that what the [ __ ]
is at NGC national Genting Oh
National Geographic has those late-night
shows about [ __ ] drug dealers drugs
Inc and all those it was one of those no
there's no regulation for it no
regulation they hire [ __ ] they go
down they hire [ __ ] ten people and
bring them into a [ __ ] thing to fill
pills all day and these people take the
pills put them in boxes and ship them
out and you don't know what the [ __ ] is
in there no [ __ ] idea that all that
it's all [ __ ] half the time yeah you
can mix in dirt and [ __ ] and put it in a
pill and sell it and call it clean
patrol and nobody regulates it you know
and it's scary I mean is scary as a
fighter what's your pain like obviously
the you don't want to cheat or be
accused of cheating but you might do you
what's your opinion on fighting someone
what do you still want to fight them if
they tested positive like if you were
like what's your opinion on the people
who do that like is it that doesn't give
you that much of an advantage um I mean
I don't I have zero idea when it comes
to what steroids does to your body as
you can tell I I probably don't just
you know I'm one of the few athletes you
know after who sada more athletes
started looking more like me with a
little pouch yeah I mean but I don't
mind it if guys are cheating which I'm
sure I fought guys that were cheating
and I beat them it don't matter to me
have you cheated you say well that's the
other side that's the other side of the
[ __ ] quote that's the other side of
it like that would suck like that I know
there's guys that are using it and
there's doctors that they're monitoring
their the levels I know it I don't know
but I know it there's out there there's
people doing steroids monitoring their
levels to where they don't go over the
limit you know and they're good at it
they're good at getting away with it but
they won't for a long time they'll be
about eventually and it sucks you know
that the odds are always against you
it sucks especially when you well look
at the Russians look at that
they were outed out of the Olympics the
Winter Olympics because everybody was
doing something something they've been
doing this is every ten I guess there
was I don't know who told me somebody
there was a doctor that had been juicing
them all this is what I heard I'm not
100% accurate this is where they told me
this doctor had the secret formula for
juicing for for performance-enhancing
drugs to where you don't fail and he had
all these Olympians juicing and then he
had all these athletes just juicing and
and he knew how to do it perfectly to
the tee he knows to science and he went
out he went out on public and said it
all and I guess now there's a hit on
this guy
Otis now that's the reason they were out
of the Olympics I don't know like that
like that that's a kind of a crazy
situation to like that would be the same
thing like the UFC and just like they're
not doing this but it'd be like the UFC
saying you have to take steroids like
here's your steroids right one that we
want exciting fights right
like the whole national team in all you
know yeah why she's been doing it
probably they've been doing it since
jesus lud Chicago it's no rush to come
no disrespect to nobody another official
they just this is what they've been been
good at for years
so I guess this doctor went out went out
in public and said how he how he was
cheating all these years and now that's
the reason they were out it and now
there's a hit on this guy I think he's I
think he's in the university minute they
did on on the doctor that had the
baseball player did you watch that
interview now what's a Alex and then
there's murder yes
Aleksandra the player did you see the
the strategy they had no I mean he had
this dummy when you make an Alex
Rodriguez money you're my doctor
baseball players are young hey tell me
my god give a [ __ ] about your practice
it's over tell those old ladies of
mañana hey I don't give a [ __ ] send them
to Coast Guard you would me from now on
and the guy was just his private doctor
well in Kelvin they had to a size yeah
I'm sure
broke they had it to such a science that
he made gummy bears for him that he
would give him in the 6th inning
edibles edibles edible [ __ ]
testosterone oh wow I believe it you
know you gotta look it up you got it
tonight when you go home and you can't
sleep go 60 minutes Alex Rodriguez is a
believer and he's talking about he would
give him these gummy bears in the 6th
inning and that's why in the eighth
inning he would always hit home runs
uh-huh because he would get that second
urge surge towards the end he had him
programmed crazy and even if he tested
him after the baseball game he would
always test clean it was crazy they had
it to a sign but when you're paying well
I'm sure I'm saying Kelvin this is all
you're gonna do your job is to make sure
I'm clean but I need to [ __ ] be dirty
and [ __ ] I need to look like Canseco but
no
[ __ ] no no way you have to know
everything about everything about
everything call your cousin call the
Chinese dude I don't give a [ __ ] who you
got a call oh yeah yeah yeah this guy
you know but um see I mean steroids are
expensive enough I mean all that [ __ ]
I'm not sure bro all that [ __ ] has gone
off the [ __ ] roof I'm sure that's
your trade
I'm sure the science is gone so yeah why
don't we were for Kanzi or what are they
of all this listen bro create maybe it's
out there
he died in 99 and I had breakfast with
him a couple months before he died and
he was a bodybuilder and he was telling
me that he paid for two treatments ten
thousand apiece will they take the juice
out of it that could that response I
don't [ __ ] know they had the powder
and then drink it ten thousands bro he
looked like he had a two-by-four you
think I'm kiddin bro I love this kid
that's crazy and he's drugged out as he
was Calvin he made sure I went to my
gigs and I got there on time you know
this is hos it he's dead now this kid
here before he died he was like a
[ __ ] tremendous bodybuilder but he
was a bodybuilder shooting snorting okay
yeah you said him oaken's he's yeah no
no this was a monster of a man monster
but part like one time he was telling me
that breakfast he goes nah they can't
catch me I got this new [ __ ] you go over
to the Bronx and it's the cadaver of the
spine and I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about he's like here it's better
than steroids he his chest looked I
remember I breakfast I was looking at
him and he was in he was off season okay
so he was broken up and Calvin he had
three inches of muscle oh that was
perfect it looked like a board it looked
like somebody and opened up his chest
and put boards in it Wow
so they got everything out there well
sure [ __ ] crazy well there's some
brother I'm happy that you took the time
we've been going back and forth from
lunch yeah yeah we have I know you're
busy and yeah I know my schedule was
crazy when I was especially when I was
out of town and the holidays stuff
visiting my mom in Arizona but I
appreciate you you you keeping in
contact man and bring me out and I like
a fun I like all the videos of you and
your mom whenever they do the [ __ ]
well you know she have a big family
support but yeah yeah but my mom really
has been the rock for my family you know
she you know I didn't grow up about it
with a dad so she it was it was her and
now you were Kings for this choice for
this now I'm at Kings for the well I've
been in Kings play past three years now
and that's home for Matt's home
Huntington Beach I dunno we time yeah
I've never met him personally I just
seen him look come on now at any time if
you're in the area is it great down
there
no the energy that you dos anos virgil's
you saw designer doesn't train there
anymore right yeah yeah I'm not true I
never knew really what fallout was
and I didn't really ask don't know you
don't know left training - exactly and
then one day he didn't show up so then
Machida trains there I train there far
be sure do trains there Marvin Vittori
trains there he's another middleweight
up-and-coming geek gotcha kasi who's
freaking monster one of the greatest he
said he's a glory kickboxer was ranked
like third in his division so we just
got a lot of world-class talent there
man
well you go Friday sparring you go there
on the sparring days you're done well
it's kind of like having a fight you
know you remember that tornado of
emotions then I talked about I get that
every Friday while long it around five
minutes five minutes I'm around five
everybody
switching over to same do switch so you
go Machida you go to Machida or every Co
I'll go and Marvin no weight limits yeah
full blast yeah full blast only Friday
only fries full blast but not really no
not like elbows and knees to the face no
no but there it's another level it's
like adding another fight to your record
and I'm taking you down I'm taking I'm
taking you down and I'm gonna punch you
in the face if I'm gonna throw my black
kick right at your face like I'm there
to to see if this shit's working yeah
exactly see if this shit's working you
know if you want to work on something if
you don't throw something you've worked
on during the week third in practice
yeah that good for you man yeah I love
it I love my time out here in SoCal I've
been to a lot of places before well see
you well I was in San Diego before that
at an alliance and then before that well
I was I was come traveling around going
to the lab
I was in lab with Benson Henderson I was
going with Ryan Bader and TVs all the
way over at power MMA in Arizona and I
went to Montreal with Rasta hobby and
George st. Pierre to check them out back
in the day yeah I just kind of been
around but I found like SoCal Rafael
Cordeiro that's what works for me
yeah well brother I wish you all the
luck in the world you're a gentleman I'm
sure gonna be champion someday
whether a17 gonna try a 185 when you
find out 170 listen when you go to
Weight Watchers bro they have they have
like points the old Weight Watchers when
I first joined sure they had points and
there was so racist they have broken
down the races okay so they have my
Cuban food
you know 26 points Cuban I need six
points you get 40 for the day and a
Cuban sandwich is 26 points Oh
when you turn to Mexican food and have a
skull and two [ __ ] bones because it
is the next bro Mexican food [ __ ]
kills you bro we both know it yeah well
Hank we lived in Colorado I had to ride
a bike
hit the bag and swim three times a week
because of not those green chile
burritos we just went back and he got a
[ __ ] loves green chile mexican
burgers and the tortillas smothered with
cheese with beans and rice that is a lot
ideas me away he's tremendous yeah I
know I mean my mom cooks everything oh
man you know when I'm back home it's
trouble so after the fight now May 12th
May 14th you go home I got to visit yeah
you go home get your head back together
I found that going on a little vacation
go kind of resets my mind pretty good
sometimes going home to your bedroom
focuses you know a bit to that yeah you
know what it hasn't changed since high
schools no so it's still there yeah and
you know the walk and you makes you feel
like you were at that time
you married no single girlfriend I got a
girlfriend
look at you you Savage you know I didn't
plan it just hasn't happened and stuff
well you look happy
I'm happy you made the trip finally to
the church they're gonna love you let me
just say two things and we'll get you
the [ __ ] out of here remember Santa Ana
Casino Albuquerque I'm coming down the
only tickets left I think a Thursday
night April 5th and then Columbus for
[ __ ] 20 I'm there the whole
weekend at the funny bone in Columbus
get your tickets now like I told you
before the show started when it comes to
uncle Joey I'm a Fujiki type of guy I'm
a SAP burrito type of guy and I got the
sakai I got the Saporito and I got the
new one but I'm a SAP burrito type of
guy it's the medium-range one like 134
and they got it for big guys hey six and
a five I just dropped from bidet 625
[ __ ] you better be looking at I'm
passing guards now and [ __ ] finally
don't be [ __ ] with me you know I love
you but anyway go to Fuji Sports calm
and press in church then I'm gonna give
you a 10% off whatever the [ __ ] you got
going on you know I'm saying help
everybody out and also on ted.com for
supplements they're my people half a
brain but after shrimp tank I will last
[ __ ] ten minutes of conditioning
class thank God i snort one and I pop
one and everybody's happy I'm kidding
it's a joke [ __ ] don't snore the
video and 18 though it's not that [ __ ]
if you're over 18 don't snore that's
dragon funnies all of a sudden it's got
a resume that I love you [ __ ] I
want to thank and wish you all the luck
in the world why Jacare you got all the
tools to beat him bro thank you
you got [ __ ] Apocalypto heart saying
hey I do have some native blood yeah
yeah yes brother yeah they know they
were there before the Mayans or that's
they were my family's from in Mexico
really yeah [ __ ] tremendous warriors
anyway I love you [ __ ] have a
great week
Kelvin Gastelum and whew
you're [ __ ] UFC champ and my manly
side I love you don't forget Albuquerque
Santa Ana casino Thursday night tickets
left only and the Columbus funny bone
with Kate Quigley that's what I forgot
to tell you
419 420 and 421 I want to thank all you
savages for listening have a great
weekend see you next Monday stay black